i want to do a quick correction to the
aim problem where we cut out a wedge of
a log in that problem so we had a wedge
so just to remind ourselves we had a log
that looked like that
we made one cut that was right along
those perpendicular to the axis of the
log we made another cut that has had a
45 degree angle so it was like that and
the solution to the problem we had to
figure out the volume of the wedge and
the big trick there was so if i drew the
wedge like this so let me take a side
view of the wedge so this is the side of
the wedge
right over here
i could shade it to show that it has
it's kind of round so if i were to shade
it you can kind of see that it is round
so this is a side view of the wedge we
knew that this right here is a 45 degree
angle and the way that we solved the
problem or the kind of trick was to say
hey if we had another wedge like this we
just stacked it on top of this one if we
just flipped it over
and made it like this that we also have
a 45 degree angle over here and then it
would make a cylinder and it's very easy
it's very easy to figure out the height
of a cylinder and i misspoke and i said
it was lucky that we had a 45 degree
angle because in the last video i was
actually visualizing it incorrectly i
said oh because if you had anything less
than a 45 degree angle this wouldn't
have worked out properly but i was wrong
it would work out properly let me show
you so if this let's say whatever
whatever angle whatever angle you have
here so this is going to be 90 degrees
over here whatever angle you have over
here so let's call that theta this over
here they have to add up to 180 so theta
plus 90 plus this has to be 180 or theta
plus this has to be 90 or this could be
you just call this 90 minus theta
now when you if i were to take the same
thing if i took another kind of wedge
like this and flipped it over over this
thing it's not this angle that's going
to be right here it's this angle so let
me just draw it right over here so it
would look like this
it would look like this
where this now is theta this end right
here is actually that end on the flipped
version and now this angle right over
here is now 90 minus theta so clearly
you have 90 minus theta plus theta so
this thing is going to be a right angle
no matter what this no matter what
obviously it has to be a reasonable
angle but no matter assuming that it's
less than 90 degrees it would have
worked out you could have done the same
trick anyway hopefully that clarifies it
and i apologize for the incorrect
visualization
in the last video